[Music]
oh
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them
happy [__] New Year
2024 how was your vacation your
holiday mine is
great I'm
ready for 2024 I'm excited about 2024
and we're going to talk a little bit
about it
today and there's so much to talk about
because we've had several days off here
and there's so many
things in the
news um one of the things in the news
is that MAA doesn't know what punk rock
is
apparently um that's
probably okay Green Day I don't know if
you guys know this green day is a punk
rock band from like the late 90s early
2000s um punk rock is
anti-establishment type music
now the problem
with culture and pop culture a lot of
times is it gets a little gray and
confusing for some dumb [__]
out there it's really kind of confusing
see a lot of people think because a
certain party is has the presidency
thinks that's The Establishment right
believes that that is the
establishment but in this country The
Establishment is everyone who looks like
me white dudes that is the establishment
and white Christian nationalism has been
the establishment for about four and a
half
decades has been the
establishment it has been the work of
the people to go against the
establishment which Maca is the epitome
of the white Christian nationalist
establishment I don't know if they know
that or
not it's really [__] weird stuff like
it's weird stuff that they they have no
clue and I I've been telling you this
for I don't know it's been about six or
eight months now I've been talking about
ideology they don't idea very
well at all and this is typical for the
fash right they're not creative they
don't idea very well they just don't
they don't mix well with I don't know
Nuance just doesn't happen with
them and the crazy part is is that green
jet day just changed one lyric like they
changed one part of the song American
Idiot which when you think about it and
when I got to thinking about it this
morning I'm
like it really does I mean that that the
title to the song American Idiot really
does describe Donald Trump like it
describes it
perfectly a silver spoon ugly [__]
wrinkly old fat white man who who earned
nothing in his entire life only
destroyed things was handed a half a
billion dollars to begin with really a
billion if you count as family lost it
all several times can't stop [__]
lying
and he has all the power and all the
control
right perfect perfect example
of a [__] American
Idiot perfect example perfect example of
the
establishment because Donald Trump is
that's why he's always been pissed
really is because the political
establishment and the money
establishment never let him be a part of
it so he had to go be part of the white
Christian nationalist
establishment that procures power
through
fear and
fascism I mean
[__] this Texas has made a decision that
a woman who is need in the need of
emergency because of a pregnancy [__]
her she can just die [__] that [__] she
can just die I'm not kidding you this is
a decision that was made we might talk
about it today oh I mean we're going to
continue to talk about this
stuff because the narrative is loose
right it's really loose and it's
starting to slip through their fingers
it's starting to slip through the
media's fingers uh this
morning uh Morning Joe I'm gonna play a
clip of them talking about polls Jesus
[__] Christ stop listening to the bu
s it is a bunch of [__] okay stop it
stop with the [__] Jesus [__]
Christ now I will say I will say some of
the the the actual narrative that needs
to happen is actually leaking leaking
through it
is and I I I know it I know it feels
like oh Tony you just you just got this
small little show there's no way what
you're saying is having effect [__] it
ain't [__] it ain't having effect I I
move the bar is what I do that's what I
do and it has an effect it has a
cascading effect yes I I may not have
millions of people watching me and I may
not have two million subscribers on my
YouTube channel but that doesn't mean
that my commentary does not have
influence
and
effect matter of fact it probably is the
exact
opposite because this is a small knit
Niche excuse me small Niche audience at
this
point it's having a huge effect
now some of the narrative that is
leaking through is and some of it is not
some of it is not because like this
morning on on uh Morning Joe they talked
about this Jeffrey Epstein list this
Donald Trump have you did you hear we're
going to get a list of Donald Trumps and
Jeffrey Epstein apparently now the right
wi is oh man they can't stop typing in
the name Bill Clinton they haven't typed
in the name Bill Clinton this much since
Hunter Biden's
laptop I mean
words not Bill Clinton I mean maybe
maybe the Jeff Jeffrey Epstein Bill
Clinton porn is on Hunter Biden's laptop
[__] I don't
know but they can't stop talking about
Bill
Clinton over the
weekend can't stop talking about
it can't stop talking about it but on
the mainstream media when this gets
brought up it gets brought up in the in
the story that Jimmy Kimbell replied to
Aaron roders now this is is crazy [__]
Aaron Rogers is a [__] box I don't I
don't even know that anyone really
should have this guy playing on their
NFL team because I don't even know if he
has enough [__] brain cells rubbed
together to to memorize a Playbook at
this point this guy does not seem like
it he's a [__] full-on q and honor
full on and this guy reads [__] on the
internet about Jeffrey Epstein and he
believes every goddamn word of it and he
goes on to
defame Jimmy Kimmel the the late night
host Jimmy Kimmel
who has a family who's a famous person I
mean he is a late night host so a lot of
people watch him a lot of people know
who the [__] Jimmy Kimmel
is and Aaron Roger goes on to defame him
on an
ESPN okay an
ESPN radio show now I I I think I'm
maybe I'm wrong about this I haven't
checked this fact but Jimmy Kimble's on
ABC right or is it CBS I don't know [__]
I don't know I don't watch Jimmy
Kimmel's show I really don't and I don't
play a lot of Jimmy Kimmel's Clips
because they're fiercely copyrighted
they [__] have teenss of lawyers that
sit and [__] go after people who play
their clips for audiences for people to
see their [__] and their content on
their shows even though we're creating
new content with it they they get
furious about it so I don't play a [__]
I don't play Jimmy's [__] and I wouldn't
play his [__] [__] because it it
[__] gets me in all kinds of trouble
needlessly
so late night hosts they produce a lot
of good comedy but it's not worth
playing and the reason why is because
they don't understand how the [__]
internet works but that's okay it's fine
it'll get better as time goes along
maybe AI will fix that [__] I don't know
maybe it'll make it worse probably
worse the point is this is that Aaron
Rogers on ESPN who is owned by ABC as
far as I am I am I off my rocker here I
don't know I haven't checked the facts
on
this but ESPN is playing Aaron roders
defaming Jimmy Kimmel on a ESPN show
airing it on ESPN and Aaron Rogers is
claiming that Jimmy Kimmel is somehow on
the list of people with Jeffrey Epstein
which there's no evidence of other than
in some fantasy [__] land that Maga
makes up where Biden's laptop is real
and [__] and and Joe Biden is a dementia
ridden evildoer who's going to take over
the world it doesn't make any sense it's
not supposed to make sense trust me it's
all
stupidity American idiots remember
American idiots we're gonna get back to
it it's a full circle trust
me but the big news or some of the big
news is that Jimmy Kimmel um takes a
clip quote tweets a clip of Aaron Rogers
saying this on an ESPN radio
show it's some stupid [__] idiots
thinking that they're manly or some [__]
talking about their toxic masculinity
and tying it to sports as if Sports and
toxic masculinity really have anything
to do with each other anyways I mean
they they want to lay claim to it but we
probably should in the American society
and pop culture take it back away from
him it's [__] ridiculous but the
point
is is that Aaron Rogers says that Jimmy
Kimmel is going to be on the list and he
can't wait for this list to come out
because it's totally going to show that
Jimmy Kimmel's on the list because Aaron
Rogers read it on Facebook somewhere
some [__] I don't know some somewhere in
the the the American Association of ior
mechon or some [__] some Facebook
group somewhere I don't know where he
read it who [__] knows where Aaron
Rogers reads his dumb [__] this guy's an
idiot he's a [__] idiot that's right
he's a [__] and he can't even throw
football he can't even keep his Achilles
heel [__] in shape [__] this guy he
can't play football and he can't do
thinking and ideas so [__] him but
anyways Jimmy Kimmel responds to Aaron
Rogers defaming him and basically says
hey [__] keep your mouth shut or
we'll get to the facts in court [__]
and my guess is if Aaron roggers has any
brain cells to rub together after um
taking horse pace for over 3 years even
though
just could get the shot my guess is is
that he won't even utter Jimmy Kimmel's
name forever and ever and ever because
really honestly this type of defamation
and we've seen it with the Rudy Giuliani
case this type of defamation where
maanga trolls go and they [__]
threaten the lives of people's families
because of stupid [__] that dumb
[__] say on the
Internet is worth couple hundred million
dollars
the thing is Rudy Giuliani isn't
anywhere near worth the money that
they put on him for the sheay Moss and
Ruby Freeman
case Aaron Rogers is worth two 300
million at least I don't know exactly
how much he's worth but he's worth a lot
of [__] money and he's got it so
Jimmy
Kimmel could could
absolutely
absolutely in a defamation suit take him
to court and probably win cuz I'm sure
Jimmy Kimmel not only has had to pay
money to protect his family from [__]
[__] boxes that Aaron Rodgers you know
gets all riled up on the [__]
internet to go send death threats to
Jimmy kiml and his family make them feel
unsafe and
unsecure but also Aaron Rogers has said
this time and time and time again so my
guess is my guess is after that tweet
twet and I I'm not for sure I mean Aaron
Rogers is a dumb [__] so it's
likely he could say something but my
guess is he probably has talked to an
attorney at this point about that
tweet and my guess is the attorney said
never mention Jimmy Kimmel's name for
the rest of your [__]
life I mean I'm no attorney you know
that I don't [__] have a law degree
it ain't hard to be an attorney though
it ain't it ain't hard to be an attorney
attorney oh my God there's good
attorneys out there but there's a lot of
[__] shitty ones and there's a lot of
grifty ones too oh man they love the
grift they love the grift grift grift
grifty grifty grift boom boom boom oh
they're going to get Trump even though
it's not gonna
happen so dumb with the stupid ominous
music trump only Justice matters it's
getting the grift is getting worse and
worse oh my [__] god it's getting
worse it's so dumb and so
stupid and I'm gonna be proven right
about this I'm very [__] confident
otherwise I wouldn't say the [__] I
don't say [__] that I'm not confident in
okay just doesn't happen the reason why
is because I'm not trying to [__]
you so if I'm not confident in it why
would I say
it why why would I [__] say it out
loud just to [__] get you to what
listen to me shovel [__] down your
throat I don't want to do that that's
the whole reason why this show has the
effect that it
has it's the reason
why because I don't [__] you and it
happens all the time I mean this morning
on Morning Joe and and outspoken on
Twitter mentioned this that morning Joe
fails Again by mentioning Jimmy Kimmel
and Aaron roders The Saga with the tweet
but they don't mention that Trump is on
the actual flight
list his name appears on the flight list
that we've already seen [__] the goddamn
list of people right I I and honestly I
could give a [__] less about this list
of people I honestly don't think it
makes a hella beans worth of [__]
difference and if you are paying
attention they're delaying this thing
there's like 170 [__] people on this
thing so every single one of them is
trying to delay this son of a [__] and
they're going to get it delayed and
delayed and delayed and delayed and
delayed now I think it's delayed to
January 89th or something I don't
[__]
know we may never see this [__]
thing this list of Jeffrey Epstein and
Donald
Trumps that we know exist in the
world you may never see it and it's the
reason why it's because it's in federal
court I keep telling you people that is
that federal court is not in a [__]
hurry they're they're not they're
not in a
[Laughter]
hurry Jesus I mean if they were really
in a hurry they'd already [__]
decided that Trump could be on the
ballot which they're going to that's
right I love The Gaslight you I love to
[__] you I love to tell you [__] you
want to hear i' love to feel you full of
a bunch of misinformation and all kinds
of [__] and it would be great that if I
told you to join this or join that or
just just read my substack so you get
the rest of the story or whatever or
come watch the podcast that you have to
pay for or watch a special episode of
the podcast and you'll learn more some
[__] like
that that ain't what this is
about I even
noticed but it's it's about [__]
winning in our democracy and winning
with democracy not using democracy to
hurt itself so we can appear to
win it's
not and yeah there's some truths that I
don't like there's some truths that you
don't
like but it doesn't give a [__] it
doesn't care the truth doesn't give a
[__] I mean take the take the two
examples of um the frothy
fervor that all the legal analysts left
and right are talking about right now
one of them is this presidential
immunity thing the left gets this wrong
all the time all the time they totally
misinterpret this
thing they act like this question is if
a president of the United States is
absolutely immune and I don't mean the
off office I mean the person who holds
the office that's not the question in
this court case the question in this
court case is Trump in His official
capacity standing on the ellipse telling
people to go hang Mike Pence quote
unquote they said it not
me he said I hope Mike Pence does the
right thing and then they went and tried
to hang him and a news they were
chanting it they whisk him away they
were looking for him that's what they
were
doing it was an
Insurrection problem is
is the question is was he acting as the
president or was he acting as candidate
Donald Trump I think that they're going
to rule that he was candidate Donald
Trump not acting in the official
capacity as the executive the president
of the United States office holder
okay I don't think that's I I think
that's do just the same as I believe
that they're not going to keep him off
the bout in Colorado in Maine or any
other
state so Trump loses and Trump wins is
that exciting to me I don't [__] I don't
know it's just it's just probably what
it's gonna [__]
be so why why are we standing around
trying to [__] form narrative based
on [__] that we know is possible we know
the possible outcomes and then we do up
stupid [__] narratives that only rely
on one one outcome and the least likely
outcome of some of those decisions why
do we do that
why the same way as with this Jeffrey
Epstein [__] wh why why do we stand
around acting like there aren't two
[__] two candidates running for
president that that were on the flight
list already Donald Trump and RFK
Jr guess who doesn't appear on those
[__] flight list anywhere anywhere on
those flight list Barack Obama does not
appear on those flight list Joe Biden
does not appear on those flight list
none of them none zero
zero
zero and I and I know a lot of people
want to talk about gas prices coming
down and they want to talk about how Joe
Biden is going to try to get borders SEC
money for borders security and and they
want to talk about biomics and all this
[__] but listen folks that [__]
doesn't win it doesn't I hate to break
it to and and and and and talking about
each Court motion of Donald Trump and
each court case that Donald Trump has
that's not going to win either it's not
going to win we're in 2024 we're almost
there to the primaries I mean we got
what [__] 12 days is it 12 days is it
January 15th is the Iowa caucus isn't
that what it is I think that's the
[__] schedule we got 12 [__] days
less than two goddamn weeks for this
thing to
start and what I mean by that is full on
election cycle
fullon so what are you gonna do you're
gonna stand around talking about every
[__] motion that Donald Trump that
Donald Trump files or are you gon to
start driving wedges down in between the
fash because oh baby are there [__]
cracks in the fash I don't know if you
noticed this Nikki Haley is really
really really really
really working for the money that she's
been
paid oh [__] yeah really working for the
money that she's paid the problem is is
it's all too late right Ronda santis
didn't work Nikki Haley didn't work no
one worked say Chris Christie thinks
he's gonna work it's not going to work
it's just not you tried but it's a cult
and they already have their chosen coat
leader so they're not going to walk away
from that they're not going to walk away
from him it's not going to happen stop
trying get with the reality get with the
[__] facts work with what you know
and form a narrative around something
that can win us this election and I'm
not just talking about the top of the
ticket that's going to be the easiest
[__] one to win folks that's going to
be easy I know a lot of people like oh
you can't don't D Tony you 2016 and bl
yeah I get it I get oh but Joe Biden and
young people and Palestinians and free
pales get the [__] out of here with this
[__] shut the [__] up with your
noise it's just noise that's all that is
that's noise listen to me listen to me
listen very [__]
carefully listen very [__] carefully
the majority of Americans don't give a
[__] about that
noise there is probably 125 130 million
people who are going to vote in this
election who don't give a [__] about
that they don't give a
[__] come down back to reality stop
living in [__] La La
Land because the longer you live in la
la land where where where you think
Americans are paying attention to every
motion that Trump loses or wins in
court you need your [__] head
checked stop listening to the [__]
poll stop watching the [__] cable
news stop watching it stop stop it I
don't care who's good and who's bad on
it stop watching that [__] trash alls
it is is grifting trash stop watching
the trash about every motion that is
filed in court every [__] true social
post oh my God people are out there
content creators are out there making
[__] videos every time Trump posts
every single time every [__] time
it's
insanity it's insanity and alls it is is
to get you to [__] give them [__]
money it's Insanity every time the cable
news says something someone gets in
front of a camera is like hey guess what
I just saw on MSNBC let me tell you the
same [__] they just
said Americans don't give a [__] about
that stuff they don't give a [__] they
don't they don't and they're not going
to clap and cheer because gasoline is
below $3 and give Joe Biden credit that
ain't how it works either that I wish it
was I said thanks Brandon because uh it
was a White House communications person
tweeted about how gasoline's below $3
Gall and I tweeted thanks Brandon and a
lot of people thought I I actually meant
that it that I thought Biden actually
had something to do with it I mean they
do they I mean they are the [__]
executive branch so there are things
they can do to try to help you know the
economy and there's certain policies
that that the economy has the foundation
of but there's no gasoline button on the
president's
desk so he's not responsible when gas
goes down or when it goes up but they
only blame when it goes up and you
should know this right you should know
this when you know this then you know
exactly how to
react when you get the news the gas
below $3 a gallon they're not going to
give credit for it they're not so
standing around begging people to give
Biden credit for gasoline is [__]
dumb it's a waste of energy it's a waste
of breath it's dumb trust me trust me on
this trust me it's it's like fighting
someone it's like trying to fight with
someone that is sure that there's no way
possible that Donald Trump's trial won't
be delayed on March 4th it's dumb as
[__] dumb as dog [__] try to argue with
someone you're never going to convince
someone that Joe Biden is the cause of
$3 gallon gas now if it goes up to $6 a
gallon over the summer [__] yeah they'll
tell you all day it's Biden's fault it's
Biden's fault it's Biden's fault that's
how America
works and I and I I know it's the cold
heart truth and I know a lot of people
don't want to hear it but look folks we
got a [__] job to do we got to save
our [__] country from the
fascist I'm going to show you some
videos today of what their plan is for
white Christian nationalism and I'm
going to show you Ronda santis repeating
that [__]
verbatim about separation between church
and state they're [__] they're they're
[__] making it to where emergency
rooms have to refuse women life-saving
Services because it might be considered
aoran
There's real [__] happening and there's
real stuff happening that we can win the
election
on Donald Trump wants to be a dictator
and he's gonna take away your rights and
they've already proven it with roie Wade
that that's how they want to do it [__]
he's bragging about it that's the only
narrative we need that's it everything
else outside of that framework outside
of they want their [__] Christianity
all up in your [__] they want to tell
you who the [__] in love they want to
tell you how to [__] dress they want
to tell you what religion how you can
talk what you can learn what you can't
learn what you should know and what you
shouldn't [__] know based on what
they
want it's
fascism everything else outside that
framework and and they want a dictator
because fascists typically like
authoritarians because the authoritarian
tells everyone what the [__] to do and
if they don't do it they [__] kill
them it's really simple it's an easy
narrative they're going to play right
into it because they're fascist and they
do want a
dictator and they want to tell us all
what the [__] to do they want to take
away our [__] Liberties and our
freedoms and they want to destroy our
democracy that's why they say it ain't
one it's a republic that's why they say
that
[__] it's all in that framework that our
narrative should be driven the entire
way every single [__] day to 2 hours
a day Monday through Friday noon Eastern
11 zentral we're back baby full [__]
Steam for 20124 on Facebook YouTube
twitch and Instagram here at the antifa
corporate headquarters in commi Falls
Missouri I bring you the Tony Michaels
podcast don't go anywhere more of the
podcast right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you ready for best pizza of
Life bring friends down to pepperoni hug
spot our chefs make pizza with heart and
Special Touch cheese pepperoni vegetable
and more secret things need delivery
pizzas come fast knock knock who's there
pizza Magic eat pepperoni hugs spot
Pizza your tummy say thank you your
mouth say m pepperoni hugs spot it's
like family but with more
cheese catch Tony's twitch stream the
[__] list Roundup at
twitch.tv/ thee Tony Michaels we're back
to the king of Brilliance this is the
Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast pizza pizza pizza Pizza speaking
of pizza news did you see that a Ninja
Turtle I'm not kidding
you the Ninja Turtle Michelangelo showed
up I think it was Michelangelo it's
either that or Raphael I couldn't tell
if it was green or orange showed up at
Mar Lago for the New Year's Rocking Eve
that's
[Laughter]
right oh my God Vanilla Ice now if you
don't know Vanilla Ice is like Maga
adjacent I don't know if he's full on
maanga but he seems maanga adjacent and
a bare minimum right um and also I don't
know if you know this but there was one
song that made Vanilla Ice super [__]
famous and super [__] Rich one hit
wonder Vanilla Ice showed up with a
Ninja
Turtle at Mar lago's New Year's Eve
party ah [__] well I'm just pointing it
out because it's easy to mock these
idiots and they I mean I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna lie um if Joe Biden actually
had some Ninja Turtles show up at a New
Year's Eve party or any party that he's
uh in charge of and he stands around and
act like it's really cool and he has
some guy from the 90s who had one good
song one hit song then um I would say I
would say go ninja go ninja go you know
what I mean like that's that's where I
would go with it cowabanga dude like
that's not a bad idea
if you want to know the honest
truth Democrats are really shitty at
that kind of stuff like they're really
stupid about it yeah they're like all
stuffy and they're like well see we want
to have a correct policy with Ukraine
and and Israel and that's what our party
theme is it's really dumb
[__] like you know what there's a point
where you shouldn't be taking yourself
seriously so much
it's one of the problems with leftwing
commentary and and left-wing
media in general is they take themselves
way too [__]
seriously it's really kind of
laughable if you want to know the truth
about it oh you're oh you're gonna
you're gonna tell me how to be
right and you know here on this show we
are not we don't take ourselves
seriously that's not the point of the
show at all it's just to try to get the
message in the narrative
out and try to give you a sense of
direction because in this world it's the
distraction is is everywhere the noise
is everywhere and that is
intentional that's [__] intentional
that's part of the system that's part of
the chaos machine that is MAA and Trump
like I said Jesus Christ they've never
typed in the words Bill Clinton more in
their [__] lives they probably don't
even really know who Bill Clinton
is if you want to know the [__] truth
about it most of these people type in
yeah Bill Clinton and Epstein like why
what the [__] do we
care number one if Bill Clinton did go
to Jeffrey Epstein's Island and they can
prove that he [__] raped underage
girls we would be the first ones to go
yeah send that [__] to jail okay
but in their world where they think
Donald Trump because he was President of
the United States gets presidential
immunity from any crime that he's ever
committed and will commit doesn't that
give Bill Clinton Presidential
presidential immunity like what what the
[__] are you people talking about it's
the same stupid [__] when they're
blaming Bon for all these crimes that
they can't prove and they don't have
evidence of and it's like yeah but in
your world the president of United
States and anyone who has ever held that
office is immune from any kind of
prosecution anywhere of any crimes that
they'd ever commit doesn't that kind of
you know make Joe Biden
immune or Bill Clinton or Barack Obama
or George W bush doesn't that make them
immune based on your interpretation of
what the law
isn't but again if you stand around
trying to [__] argue with
him it's a futile
effort that's why you just got to point
it out you got to point at them you got
to mock them you got to mock them
properly you got to point out why you're
mocking them make the Point Drive The
Narrative and people will
know that's how it [__] works that's
how it works now the media is starting
to catch they still are terrible at this
especially Morning Joe and I don't know
if it's like the late night producers
because I know there's some producers
that watch this show you know they're I
I think they're probably they
reluctantly
because you're probably [__] I gota
watch Tony I'm what are you assigned to
do this week I gotta watch [__] Tony
next question oh my God and they want me
to watch him live so I can't even like
do it in fast speed of course these
[__] can't really watch me in
fast
speed because there is no dead air I'm
not like some other host where I'm like
um
so you guys tell me what you think and
then I'll I'll tell you what I think to
make you happy okay
no that a what we do here that is not
what we do
here but it is leaking through a little
bit I will tell you that the narrative
is leaking through a little bit because
they are [__] listening and I and I
know it I know it it seems like I'm
patting myself on the back or I have too
much confidence but folks just go watch
the [__] of what it was three months ago
and what I was saying three months ago
and what they're saying now and I'm
telling you there's a correlation I I've
showed you I've showed you and I don't
really like to compare myself to him
it's the idea of how information and how
narrative leaks right and how it
Cascades
out um I've showed you videos of like
Nick Fuentes most people don't even know
who [__] Nick Fuentes was I've been
showing videos of Nick Fuentes for for
years on this
show and a lot of people don't
understand how his message Cascades but
it Cascades that's how I that's how I
kind of know what they're going to say
before they [__] say it because I go
watch that [__] I see what they're
saying I see what all those little
[__] things are saying and it
Cascades out and I know it's going to
Cascade
eventually the same way here this little
show we say crazy [__] we talk about
dildos and butt plugs and all kinds of
crazy [__] and we talk about politics
too and how sometimes the left is dumb
and stupid and the right is absolutely
[__] lost their minds and the fash
has grabbed a hold of the right and
really suck the blood out of
them so much so that they're talking
about blood poisoning Hitler mind C typ
[__] just in English not in German
they're saying it differently you
know but that's how messaging works
that's how narrative
works that's how it works the right is
really good at it the right is really
good at
it they know messaging
Cascades the left doesn't understand
that very well they think they can make
me and other folks like me get their
messaging from up top right they think
oh it's trickle down
messaging it's trickle down
messaging they don't quite understand
how populism takes hold
and there's good populism and bad
populism all these are ideas by the way
it's called
ideology it's all part of ideology and
again the media thinks that they can do
trick trickle down ideas trickle down
messaging trickle down narrative that's
not how it works it it it used to be how
it works before like AM radio and
[__] internet like that used to be
how it works because the only thing that
they were listen listening to was those
people so you heard it and you knew it
but that ain't how it is
now the Wright has understood this for
decades it's the reason why they win
messaging it's the reason why over the
weekend every stupid [__] on the
internet was typing in the name Bill
Clinton every [__] one of them it's
the reason why okay because they can't
defend that Donald Trump's on these
flight logs they can't defend
that because if they defend it they're
admitting
it so they ignore they ignore that fact
and they just go with the populace
messaging that they want for their side
now
again to think that the only thing that
people in this country care about is
Bill Clinton going to Jeffrey Epstein's
Island when Bill Clinton is light years
away from president by the way based on
our Constitution Bill Clinton could
never never be our president again I
don't know if they know that either I
know they want a dictator like they want
one so [__] bad like can't stand it
they want a president who could just be
president forever if we could just have
a name for like dict taster or
something but Bill Clinton can't be
president again he's not going to run
for president
again neither is Hillary okay I know you
have this [__] wet dream where
Hillary swoops in and takes over the
nomination for Joe Biden and Donald
Trump beats her and then hangs her at
gitmo or some weird [__] but she's not
going to run for president dude she's
not and really honestly if there's
evidence against Bill Clinton I I could
give a [__] less if they put him in
prison honestly if he did what you're
saying he did they probably should
but the same goes for your
dude but again this is all messaging and
narrative okay it's not reality right
and what matters what really matters to
right-wingers is that they create an
alternate reality that Americans can
believe because you got the truth right
you got the truth that they can believe
and then they need something else to
choose options they want options they
want options they want
democracy I want option I want I want
idea options which we do we have idea
options that's the point of Liberty and
freedom you
see is we got options between IDs
ideas with a z
z we got options because we have Liberty
and freedom we get to we get to
actually we get to
actually
to we we get to
decide what our ideology is
individually right because ideas are
individual they're not always the same
it's quite obvious especially here on
the Tony Michaels podcast with the [__]
them
fan listen they will never people who
are really part of the [__] fam here
they will never accuse us of being as a
part of a cult right never [__] never
and they will never accuse me of being a
cult leader because anyone who's anyone
who knows especially like on Discord who
thinks like I rain down on them and I'm
the dictator and I'm the
king you're wildly out of
Step but the reason why is because we
welcome descent we welcome debate
between ideas
right but that's not what a lot of folks
do in this country that's what we really
should get back to is a is a descent
type discourse but the problem is is
there's a lot of people in this
country who won't agree on a certain set
of facts and the reason why is because
just what I was saying the facts don't
don't support their [__]
bias they don't just like on the left
sometimes the facts don't support their
bias like U oh my God I can't I I can't
tell you how [__] tired I am I am
[__] sick and tired of hearing about
how this conflict in Gaza is somehow an
an a domestic American
election problem shut the sh shut the
[__] up number one stop stop talking
about it then shut the [__]
up shut the any anyone out there
giving you their [__] hot take on
[__] Gaza and Israel and Hamas giving
you their hot take I don't give a [__]
who they're supporting what their
[__] slogan is it has nothing let me
let me let me tell you it has nothing
nothing to do with
domestic election polic politics right
now in this year not a goddamn thing no
boots on the ground
we we are we we are we cannot we cannot
take over the sovereign state of Israel
to unseat BB
Netanyahu we are not the ones
responsible for going in and getting rid
of Hamas the the actual oppressors of
the Palestinians who have deluded them
into believing that that a a fascist
theocracy will will take them to the
Homeland so they can exterminate Jewish
people to take back their again the
stupid little spot on earth
listen if you think that's good for
domestic politics or talking about it at
all you're a dumb
[__] if you think that's going
to help our side and talking about it
it's going to help the narrative in our
side yeah I know there's news you got to
report the news blah blah blah blah blah
I get it I get
it but I'm I'm not here to really report
every single piece of
news to you that's not what this is
about this is about [__] our
democracy this about our [__] C our
country America
first I guess maybe you could consider
me an isolationist during an election
cycle but let me tell you something the
majority of people who are going to vote
in the 2024
election almost none of them almost none
of them who are going to cast a
ballot are casting about based on what
the [__] happening in Ukraine based on
what the [__] happening in God
they're
not that's the [__] truth and I don't
give a [__] what polls say what where it
ain't G to happen that's not how it
works it's never worked that way it
won't work that
way now I'm going to show you a couple
Clips here of
MSNBC and they're contradictory I'll
agree they're contradictory now one is
from the 11th hour with Ste with with
with Stephanie what's her name [__] I
don't I I don't watch that
much um it's John fugle saying um saying
[__] I've been saying for three [__]
years I think John's been saying it
similarly too I'm not I'm not accusing
John of not saying this but the
messaging is
leaking oh yeah yeah um um someone in
the Discord says Stephanie hot as [__]
rule I mean I'm not I'm not going to
disagree I think listen I think I I
think Stephanie rule is [__] a smoke
show yeah sure why not I mean she's
beautiful hell there's a lot of the
women on Fox news that are smoke shows
they're
beautiful I mean I'm not taking that
into account of how I you
know take what she says seriously I I
mean I I do in some instances but I I
don't because she's on MSNBC but let me
show you here this is a clip um from
Stephanie hot as [__] um as Natty puts
it over zephy Z puts it over in in in
Discord um this is John fugles sing on
Stephanie's show 11th Hour which used to
be Brian Williams Show by the way um and
and this I think this is supposed to be
like a round table of comedians I think
it's what it's supposed to be I believe
that's what it's supposed to be and John
here um is comedian now he also does
political commentary that's the other
thing that I think the left doesn't do
wrong but we don't do enough of is we
let certain people commentate for the
left when we should just have
commentators like
me I just C people who talk talk [__]
[__] talkers that's right I'm the circus
clown okay the left needs more [__]
circus clown to distract
you know what I mean okay here is John
but listen to what he says uh in this
clip in South Carolina they tried to
have a bill this year calling for the
death penalty for abortion we're so
pro-life will'll kill you that's where
we're at right now we're so pro life
that will kill you now it's a pretty
short clip um but it is leaking through
now the reason why John gets to be on
MSNBC in this hour is because it is
called the night cap it is the round
cable with a comedian and he's able he's
able to say this on air on a cable TV
show right uh Brenda says she stopped
watching Ms
MSNBC yeah I you probably should most of
it I mean some people some people still
like a few of them like Stephanie or um
or um I I don't know
uh uh uh uh Joy Reed Lawrence o' Donald
some people like that and Chris Hayes
he's kind of [__] boring Rachel mat's
got such a big contract but she Ain on
that much anymore from what I understand
so Ari melber's pretty good at some of
the legal commentary he's pretty good at
it I'll admit he's pretty straight down
the line he doesn't [__] most people
now when you when you
ask them someone asked would I ever go
on Bill Mah [__] yeah I would oh yeah
I'd go on Bill Mar and eat his ass [__]
yeah i' tell Bill how he's changed I
watch I watch listen I've watched bill
Mar since I was probably let's see when
was Politically Incorrect um first aired
because it first aired on Comedy Central
and then they moved it to NBC
um let me see when it
was so the and he got kicked off the air
because uh 1993 so I was probably
watching Bill Maher Politically
Incorrect in
1996 97
uh when I was just a young wee little
man and I would tell Bill how he's
[__] changed now he doesn't think he
has but
would what what
what
um wh what's the Texas Paul thing I
don't know I don't know everyone keeps
asking about Texas Paul what do you mean
what happened to him I don't was he not
on today I have no idea what happened
with Texas Paul what happened with Texas
Paul what what what did he say something
what happened what happened what
happened Amanda says Texas Paul's
dedicating time to his own show I mean I
guess so what what's what's wrong what's
wrong what what's going on what what in
the
universe is tearing you apart that that
has to be done
today um someone says tar I'm a new
[__] Tony I I don't know if you mean
Texas ball or if you mean Politically
Incorrect Bill mAh but I've been
watching Bill Mario but yes I would go I
would go on Bill Mar
show I would go on Bill Mar
show so I I guess I guess because Texas
Paul is still
live Texas Paul is still live and so
people are concerned I don't know you
can go watch Texas Paul you can watch me
which I mean doesn't make me Texas Paul
Story please what I don't know what
you're talking
about I mean
I guess maybe I should I should ask
Texas
Paul is Texas Paul talking about me over
on in show maybe he did maybe he is hell
I don't
know it would be funny it'd be
funny oh big step fan it says is it
because Texas Paul is competing with you
right I mean not competing I mean how's
on too isn't he Ian there's a lot of
shows on right now there's a lot of
shows on right now I'm not going to
change my time [__] that [__] this is my
time I've been doing this time
forever so
anyways oh Texas Paul getting right into
the Gaza stuff yeah Texas Paul talks a
lot about Gaza he talks a lot about Gaza
he talks about a lot of he talks about a
lot of stuff on his social media and his
channel that ain't got to do with [__]
that is going to be a factor in this
election I mean if you want to know if
you want it if you want the honest truth
from me about that yeah
sure that that's it's what's
happening Eye Off the
Ball eye off the ball um Coco says Tony
would kill on Bill I would kill on Bill
Mah he would never have me on
probably yeah they would never have me
on I mean maybe maybe possibly they
might not be able to ignore me would be
the actual proper way of putting it
uh but anyways what were we talking
about [__] you got me off all TR on
track
now um big step fan says that's more
with what Hal Sparks does with the
foreign stuff than Tony does I don't do
foreign
narratives I don't do foreign narratives
and there's a reason for this show
that's the reason why I tell you that
you won't find a show like this anywhere
on the left you won't find a show like
this anywhere on the left you won't I
mean you should go tell your [__]
family your friends everyone on social
media that you're not going to find a
show like this on the
left because I don't do that type of
[__] that's why I say a lot of people
think me and Hal are similar and I'm not
knocking Hal I'm just his show is
different it's about different
stuff my show is about the domestic
political narrative and winning [__]
elections against fascism this machine
kills fascist and you are the ones who
power this
machine you are the ones who power this
machine against fascism you the
audience and I know and I know it's a
long hard SLO like um here in a couple
weeks it'll be three years that I've
been doing this three years that I've
been doing a show not a couple months
not three times a week or twice a week
or what I do a podcast once a week oh
good for you good for you how's your
sponsors
doing that's not what this show is about
the show is about driving a political
domestic
narrative that will beat the fash
that'll get them to crawl back
underneath their [__] rocks because
because I've seen it coming for a long
time and I've said it over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
and over again and I'll keep saying it
because I'm not going to give up I'm not
going to give up on my country I'm not
going to give up on the American people
I'm not going to give up on you and I'm
definitely sure as hell not going to
give up on the Constitution and our [__]
and and our [__] democracy not GNA do
it and I'm not going to
sell sell out to do it
won't
happen you're not going to get me to do
it now I got to make a living right like
if I don't make a living then we don't
get to do
this we don't get to do
this that's where I mean that's where
you guys come in to view it every single
day to share it a lot of you guys are
patreon members and and I got to I got
to thank everyone because um we we we've
had over 200 paid patreon members for a
long time which isn't a lot but all of a
sudden we have almost 500 people who are
following on patreon which is really
cool and it's free to follow me on
patreon and I noticed a lot of people
went from like the $5 category to free
but a lot of people have joined too so
I'm not really in particular worried
about you know the EB and the flow of it
because that's how it
happens but your support means more than
anything in this effort in this year now
that we're in
2024 and we're so close to the election
cycle actually kicking off because that
that's the other thing that a lot of
commentators really don't [__] know
and don't understand they don't get
primaries they don't understand that
there's two different elections that's
why the 14th Amendment [__] is getting
all confused people get wildly out of
Step the media is starting to finally
realize that the 14th Amendment stuff
really isn't going to [__]
happen
I mean even the commentators on the
MSNBC start best says I can join patreon
for free yeah you can join you you can
follow me over there on patreon for free
just go to Theon michaels.com hit the
patreon and you can follow for free a
lot a lot of people a lot of people have
done a yearly a yearly uh amount because
you get 10% off if you if you buy
yearly and and it helps keep my
microphone on because this is what I do
for a living now this is what I do and
no it's not as lucrative as other things
I've done in my
life but I think it's more important
than anything I've ever
done
ever and I'll ever do and honestly I
want it to be my
legacy that I used what I have
best to try to make my country better
for everyone here everyone I don't give
a [__] what color race Creed where you
come from whether you're
here documented or undocumented male
female I don't I don't give a [__] if
you're here you're here and that's what
I
want that's what I
want so if you're supporting me if
you're supporting
me um here at the show whether you're
watching you're sharing the link uh
you're helping me cuz I'm throttled on
Twitter
because I didn't buy a blue check
mark you buy merch you contribute to the
swear jar or you buy shots or you're a
patreon member thank you so much because
you really do you really do keep this
microphone powered on against fascism it
is
you I don't have big sponsors here I
mean I've looked for them we've
tried but I've never fit their
mold and the reason why I don't fit
their mold is
because I'm not here to sell anything
but
democracy I'm not here to [__] you
I'm not here to tell you the [__] you
want to hear so you'll stick around for
the ad you know what I mean I mean I
have the stupid [__] AI Pizza
commercial and Gabe
Sanchez parody commercials that's our
commercials they're not even
real they're [__]
fake that's probably the most lying I do
to you is in the commercials that we
play because I don't actually have
sponsors because none of them will
sponsor me because of the [__] I say and
how I say it and I know that sounds
crazy because you're like but Tony
there's plenty of people that say the
crazy [__] you say yeah but they're not
looking through the lens that I'm
looking
through like I said how many times do
you hear me say the current president of
the United States name on a daily basis
how much do I time do I spend bragging
about how great he is
because I know that's not going to win
The Narrative
folks I don't know if you notice this
but the economy is
roaring but the American people don't
believe it do you know how hard it is to
convince
people that that one person is is
responsible for everything it's really
[__] hard especially in this day and
age because people just don't believe
that
[__]
the American people are responsible for
the economy
folks do you know how many [__] you
know how many [__] PE union members
this year renegotiated their labor
contracts do you know how significant
that is do you know how scared
corporations
are of Labor and unions and people
saying no you're going to [__] pay us
you how terrified they
are that is the American economy not Joe
Biden not Donald Trump not the whoever
the [__] president of the United
States is not whoever is the Fed
chairman yeah they have control they
have power there's certain things they
can do and if they're derelict and their
Duty it can all go to
[__]
listen
it is
us the power of us we the
people we need to have that messaging
more everyone is so scared of a populace
message because they think that it
snowballs into something like Maga but
it doesn't have
to an ideology does not have to to to
build around an occult personality it
doesn't
I know a lot of things that I say on
this show seem like crazy and backwards
and they just don't [__] hardly
compute with what you're reading on
social media or what you're hearing from
the Democrats or or or or influencers or
people who have two or three million
subscribers on their YouTube channels
well there's a reason for
it
there's a reason for
it it's because it's not very um
marketable the what I say and how I say
it isn't very marketable for me to sit
here and say oh well it Joe Biden ain't
Our
Savior that's not very marketable for
the
Democrats for the established
M isn't very marketable for the people
who want to try to
sell to
sell one candidate or one idea right I
don't know what Christopher says here
but it looks like it's important it says
that's vague Tony an effected president
is that because of the team he or she
has the decision process values goals
they have fail to realize great leaders
have great teams exactly exactly that's
the and guess what guess what guess what
Christopher we are their team in
democracy president of United States can
be the best president ever in the
history of ever
ever and if they don't team up with the
American people the American people can
dump
them that's the entire [__]
point it's the whole [__]
point the whole
point we get to descent even if you're
doing good we get to
descent and the more we stand around
trying to figure out why people aren't
giving Joe Biden credit the longer we're
goingon to
lose okay it's just gonna happen that
way and the more you listen to the polls
and the more you get worried that people
are going to blame Joe Biden for the
good economy
what we have to give them a reason to go
vote against something I
know that sounds negative as hell right
oh man that sounds really bad
Tony do we really want to have that kind
of a negative message how do you think
people get
elected how do you think this works
man that's exactly how it works
that's exactly how it
works and honestly Joe Biden having a
good team is good for us so now we know
we know the guy puts his [__] shoes
on he gets up in the morning he does his
[__] job and he's got a great team
around him so what the [__] are you
worried about that [__] for stop stop
building your narrative around [__] you
shouldn't be worried about
stop stop it stop
it well we should worry about Donald
Trump so we should consume every single
video that is against Donald Trump stop
that [__]
too you're getting down rabbit holes and
losing the [__] focus on what is
gonna happen in
2024 again Grant Paul Hitler is gonna
take away your rights like he already
did with roie Wade he's taking credit
for it Focus
focus
focus and every single issue in this
country can be tied to that every
[__] one of them you don't need to be
distracted by any kind of
noise let me show you let's see
here oh here we go here you
go Ah that's too that's too overt we'll
uh we we'll go we we'll move on past
that here here here's a better one
here's a better
one here's cudow on Fox Business you
know what I'm beginning to think and
watching this clip I'm beginning to
think that Fox Business sh that's a
worst moniker than Fox News you know
what I mean like honestly Fox News is
bad like it's not it's not news at all I
don't know [__] about the news but Fox
Business I'm beginning to think it's
even worse listen to this [__] I want to
go into one of my favorite topics
biomics while it's perfectly true that
the third quarter recent months at least
in terms of GDP was a stronger economy
than expected okay it's also true that
inflation rates have come down
un
undeniable but we really want to
dictator we want to taste his dick is
what we want we want a dict taster do we
taste his dick or does taste our dick
I'm not really sure how does the dick
tasting thing work they really want a
dictator they're salivating for it they
have been for a long
time don't be mad at me this is what
they want this is the
reality that they live in here I'll show
it to you again listen to what he says
he loves the topic of what what was it I
want to go into one of my favorite
Topics by
dyamics while it's perfectly true that
the third quarter recent months at least
in terms of GDP was a stronger economy
than expected okay it's also true that
inflation rates have come down
undeniably true oh okay so I could do
the whole [__] leftwing thing and be
like yeah but here's what you're missing
about Biden and Joe Biden how good he's
doing and and here let let's have a
discussion about let's fight about Joe
Biden that's the dumb [__] ever did you
see do you see the difference between
the first time that I did it and the
second time what was the difference what
was the difference what was what was the
difference here's the difference I said
but we want a
dictator that turned the conversation do
you see do you see the narrative do you
see how it you see how it drives like
cow admitted that the [__] economy is
good but but what are you going to argue
with these [__] idiots about Biden in
the economy and trying to convince them
that they should vote for Biden because
it's a great economy or or you going to
drive the narrative home that the econom
is good but you still want a
dictator it's weird stuff you're
admitting that you want a you're
admitting you say you want a good
economy economy is good but you want a
dictator why do you want
that that's the
difference there's one clip all right
let's do this again
H let me show it to you again here I'll
show it to you here I know it seems like
we're in class
here let's see what's a good one here
let me find a good clip here I was gonna
talk
about I gotta show you this one it's
hilarious um here you go here you go
here here's one Chris Christie this
morning oh Morning
Joe huh if you need to know where
morning Joe's at here's where you know
where they're at Chris Christie's on
there because he's anti-trump Tony he
says anti-trump stuff just just listen
to him he says anti-trump stuff okay
well let's listen Governor Christie good
to see you I just want to follow up on
something you just said a moment ago uh
you know certainly you're resisting
calls to drop off pre- new H Drop Out
pre- New Hampshire you made that case
very clear but you just said that you
plan to stay in you know through
potentially the Trump legal process
which we don't know when it could occur
but it certainly wouldn't be before
March April and Beyond so do you see
yourself riding this all the way to the
convention even if uh you know you you
have struggled to attract delegates at
that point well look John I think we're
going to make that AAL valuation as we
go along but uh at some point um as this
stuff starts to fall apart the
Republican voters are going to need an
alternative who has made this made it
very clear that they're against Donald
Trump and that they predicted this was
going to happen all along and I've been
saying it ever since I got into the race
unlike anybody else in the race and so
you know this is never going to be easy
when I got into the race I said
everybody is an underdog and that's why
this kind of sophistry about who should
get out of the race is kind of
ridiculous I mean in the end everyone is
a long shot in this race but Donald
Trump on the Republic everyone is a long
shot in this race but Donald Trump
because Chris Christie [__] knows
that it's a
cult he knows the end result he knows he
knows Chris Christie's main goal is to
save the Republican Party
period period listen to what he says
listen if you don't [__] believe me
that he's not here he is not [__]
here to save our country if you [__]
think that Chris Christie is running to
save our democracy save our country you
are [__] wrong you're wrong listen to
the to the slit that he has here listen
Republican side if you believe the
polling and so the question is who's
standing on principle who's going to do
what's right for the part who's going to
do what's right for the what for the
what for the what the country is that
what you meant Chris Christie cuz it
sounded like you're going to say
something else let's let's listen
Republican side if you believe the
polling yeah and so the question is
who's standing on principle who's going
to do what's right for the part who's
gonna do what's right for
the
party he said what he [__] he said
what he's in it for folks same reason
why Liz Cheney Adam kinzinger Paul
Ryan they're not in it to help us with
democracy they want to save their party
not democracy get it [__] straight
okay get it [__] straight until you
come to that
reality you're G to be wrong every
[__] time same reason why you're
going to be wrong about the 14th you're
going to be wrong about this you're
going to be wrong about about that
because you're not down to [__]
reality what reality is and the reality
is Chris Christie is trying to sell you
that he's doing it for democracy but
really he's doing it for his party
listen listen to how he how he's well
let's back it up just a bit watch how he
flips on it watch the polling and so the
question is who's standing on principle
who's going to do what's right for the
part I view this as a fight for not the
soul of my party but for the soul of our
country oh oh oh oh oh oh who the [__]
on who the [__] who has a show two hours
a day Monday through Friday noon Eastern
11 Central 9 Pacific has been saying for
years it's 2023 almost Years and we're
gonna I don't know if you know this but
we
are we are three
years or excuse me 2024 holy [__] it's
January 3rd 2024 we are just three days
away from three years of January
6 I've been bashing on Liz Cheney for
two and a half
years two and a
half I've been saying she's only in it
for her
party I mean I'm not gonna stop her I'm
not gonna let I'm not gonna stop her
from doing her parallel fight with
Donald Trump with us but get it straight
her fight is not is not the means to
ends folks it's not let me let me show
you another [__] example do what's
right for the
part let me show you another [__]
example here um over the weekend that I
saw a clip of Paul Ryan and I know I
know I know it's kind
of weird that I sit here and
pay um there's that that clip but I
there's a longer clip I thought um of
Paul Ryan that I really want to play
here hang on let me find it and then
we'll get to the Green Day stuff I got
to show you this Green Day stuff it's
hilarious maybe I'll show you the um the
Ninja Turtle thing and then also um
where in the [__] is it and then also
the
um what what else was there Green Day
the Ninja Turtle something else
something else I was going to show you
look it's
Raph yeah a little too Raph
you a little too R oh yes oh yes I was I
was I was going to show you um maybe
some Epstein stuff um that these idiots
are saying that there's white Christian
nationalism I want to show that too um
here we go here here here well here's
one of the Paul Ryan Clips let's watch
this one it's only 15 seconds let's
listen to this you know the party seems
to be in a different place than when you
got into it and uh why is that what's
going to happen what the hell is wrong
with the Republican Party in the US and
uh and perhaps politics more broadly how
much time do you have what's the uh well
I'll give you a two-word answer Donald
Trump Donald Trump oh hey Donald Trump
is the problem with our party he's the
problem oh really really you [__]
[__] box guess who made Donald Trump
guess who made them now um Republicans
account ility actually account
accountable GOP whatever the hell they
call themselves um put out these clips
and I know that they're doing this to
try to
support um you know the idea that Paul
Ryan's goingon to be welcome into the
pro democracy fold well he shouldn't be
he [__] shouldn't be [__] Paul Ryan
[__] that [__] right here is the clip
that I was going to show you earlier
this is why you should say [__] Paul
Ryan we have populism that has pervaded
our party that has taken over um a big
big chunk not all but a big chunk of our
party it's what you think of as a
Republican party now it's populism
untethered to principle wrapped around
the cult personality of Donald Trump
this is not a populism that is that is
anchored in some kind of core philosophy
other than you know his personality and
so that's that's a bad place to be right
now it's not a successful governing
mandate if it's what we run on this time
around I think we're going to lose again
uh so to me the sooner we can get past
this the better we're going to be
yeah you hear that we we he says we he
doesn't mean America he doesn't mean
Americans he's saying that this these
ideas are dangerous but he's not talking
about Americans he's talking about his
party it's a cult it's a cult it's a
cult I don't give a [__] who the cult
leader
is they are party first and only
first we this we [__] we we we we we we
we listen and I'm all for populism I
want to make you know my ideas popular
but I want them to be tied to a
principle I want them to solve problems
sure and not to be wrapped around some
guy's personality which is screwed up as
as his is it's not a good personality to
wrap yourselves around
right where were you in 2016
[__] where were you when you were
cheering with him to kill Americans
Health Care to take away Americans
health care and their [__] their
access to healthare Paul Ryan where the
[__] were you when we needed you huh oh
that's right when you're saying we you
don't mean us the people the American
people this is why I keep telling you I
keep telling when and I'm gonna say it
and it's going to piss some of you off
because a lot of you got pissed off when
I brought up the Michael Cohen story
last week as if it was my [__] fault
you guys were pissed off at me that
Michael Cohen made a mistake and oh by
the way I want to clarify something
Michael Cohen absolutely knew that was
AI 100% knew it was AI you gotta sign up
for that AI you gotta sign up for it and
it's got disclaimers all over it that
it's that it that it's
AI I'm gonna say it if you're pulling on
someone like Adam kininger to [__]
make a point against Donald Trump what
the f who gives a [__] if Adam kininger
says that Trump smells who gives a [__]
everyone could say that you could look
at you can look at just videos of him
and know that he [__] smells you
telling me that Adam mck kininger is the
only one that can answer the question
rather Trump smells weird or not the
[__] out of here this is the dumbest
[__]
ever I will
never quote me on this I will never ever
ever act like this [__] right
here because I know who this
[__] is I've watched him come up
through the ranks I watched him
reluctantly become speaker that ruined
his [__] career I watch that
[__] just act like Donald Trump
was gonna be a stupid wet pen for his
stupid [__]
agenda that's what that's what he's
truly mad about this guy is truly mad
that he didn't get what he wanted which
was to get to do whatever the [__] he
wanted he ain't got he ain't got he
ain't on our side he ain't on Democracy
side
folks neither is Liz Cheney neither is
Adam kininger who's trying to revive the
Republican party in every single [__]
interview why in the [__] would I have
on
anyone unless I wanted to dunk on them
hard which I probably would I'd have
Adam k on he wouldn't like it he
wouldn't be on my show probably he
wouldn't he wouldn't be on my
show cuz they
know they know what the end result would
be I would not go easy on them like the
rest of the [__] media are people
pretending to be the
media are trying to copy to be the
media you know who I'm talking
about it's it's [__] weird and it's
gross it's gross and kiner going around
a media tour about how he wants to
revive the Republican party and then he
shows up on pro-democracy media as if
he's part of the pro-democracy Coalition
by Reviving a party who have who have
welcomed in the [__]
Nazis that's right Adam
kininger Paul Ryan Liz
Cheney Kevin McCarthy all of them
welcome in the [__] Nazis the fascist
and they knew it they [__] knew
it they [__] knew
it
listen so McCarthy uh uh basically takes
the conversation and turns it to what is
happening in the United States he Begins
by saying I'll guarantee you that's what
it is the Russians hacked the DNC and
got the op research that they had on
Trump and then McCarthy laughs McCarthy
then adds there's two people I think
Putin pays roarer and Trump they knew it
the whole time
man they knew it the entire [__]
time it's not hard
to understand these
things you can ignore them like you can
ignore the fact of who [__] Adam
kinger and Paul Ryan is you can ignore
those
facts just to get a a fancy little
[__] hashtag going and I'm I'm gonna
agree the hashtag Trump smells is a good
one like it pisses him off it pisses
Maga off like it's a good one but you
don't you don't have to you don't have
to
[__] degrade
Yourself by having someone who's trying
to revive the Republican Party damn our
democracy to do
it because this is what they truly want
let me show you what they [__]
want you want to see what they want
here's what they want my goal is to be
faithful before God each day with each
opportunity that comes in place and I
want to encourage people to run for
office local office hold those are very
important and well we we seeing that
with Schoolboard races all across this
country how we are turning public
education um because parents are running
for those School Board School Board
County Board Sheriff mayor all very
important positions and um you know we
need people that fear God that believe
they can't hide from God and ultimately
they're going to give account to God
those are the best people to hold
position
whether it's local or in the federal
government they want a they
want a fascist
theocracy it's what they want they're
salivating for
it
salivating folks keep your eye on the
ball here I'm I'm gonna show you some
more here hang
on don't touch that dial because I'm
about to show you some more [__]
crazy [__] that they've
said yeah I'll show you that that God
email here in a second because that's a
good
laugh you know the you know the god
email lady oh it's a great laugh it's a
great laugh but I want to show you I
want to show you this Christian
nationalism how it's leaking through
what you just saw that's what they
really want is the Christian
nationalism and it's leaking through and
it's really leaking through um through
this idea that we don't want to have sep
oparation between church and
state is where it's really starting to
you know come apart and here's Bill cook
some kind of [__] crazy white
Christian nationalist listen to him
listen to him here listen to him say
what she was saying listen but listen to
him talk about the
fundamental value of separation between
church and state that we have in this
country for liberty for people to choose
their religion or choose not to have it
listen to what he says backwards about
it the idea that that there's separation
of church and state the way that it's
been been manipulated by leaders in our
government is absurd it's absurd it is a
fraud and it is
tyranny it absolutely it's time that
every time that every person every
Pastor who loves Liberty who loves
religious freedom stands up and says no
we aren't doing it anymore we're not
we're not playing this game of
separation of church and state anymore
they want a fascist
theocracy they're saying it out
loud listen to them I'm telling you I'm
telling you telling you over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over again this is the
danger this is the
danger these Theocratic
fascist these white Christian
nationalists these [__] ninka poop
Nazis own Lock Stock Barrel the
Republican party they control the power
apparatus they control the [__] money
apparatus they control it all it's
theirs the Republican party is now the
ninka poop American Nazi party
okay you can't go back you can't unaz
yourself that is not how it
works can you imagine can you imagine if
someone started a national socialist
party in Germany today like no no no no
no no no no we're not going to be like
the other Nazis okay it's not like the
little mustache guy notti Nazis okay
we're rebranding is what we're doing see
we're not it's it's a new Nazi today is
the new Nazi party just imagine that in
Germany right probably wouldn't [__]
fly I don't know if people would believe
that [__] you know what I
mean you don't get the Sten of Nazi off
you and Skip in Discord says they just
did that with the afd yeah but they're
Nazis they're [__] not you don't get
to stitch a Nazi off you like neo-nazis
in this country have rebranded and
rebranded and rebranded and rebranded
and now they're embed with the Christian
nationalists and they're white Christian
nationalist in this country and they're
[__] Nazis
the Nazi agenda is the Republican agenda
the Republican agenda is the Nazi agenda
okay they're one and the same and it
doesn't matter what Paul Ryan says what
Adam kinzinger says what Liz Cheney says
what Chris Christie says what [__]
Nikki Haley says it doesn't
matter you don't wash the stench of Nazi
off of
you doesn't happen that way and what
they want is a Theocratic fascist Nation
if if we value Liberty we have to we
have to fight and we have to stand
against this absurdity SE this absurdity
called separation of church and state we
may not like it it may go contrary to
our flesh and nature but we have to do
it it's What God Says to do Jesus sent
his disciples into the world to preach
the gospel of the Kingdom his kingdom
and we're called to obey him in whatever
we do so yeah I can't imagine there's a
government on Earth that's contrary to
the kingdom of God well if it is it's
not it's not a government
so no it's not it's not a government oh
oh it's not a government do you hear it
do you hear it do you [__] hear it
now I know I know you're like Tony this
is some wild [__] on some wild stupid
show that no one's ever heard about who
are these [__] chuckle [__] who are
these [__] eaters no one's listening to
them at all there's no way that this
could be dangerous at all like I don't
know like maybe like I don't know like
like someone who thinks are right
running for president of Iowa could say
it I don't know maybe I have rendered
very sharp uh contrast between uh Donald
Trump and myself with respect to policy
um for example he's running on a lot of
the things he promised to do in 2016 and
didn't deliver on he said he was going
to build a wall and have Mexico pay for
it didn't do it he said that he was
going to drain the swamp didn't do it he
said he was going to eliminate the debt
and yet he added $7.8 trillion do to the
debt so those were not things that he he
dealt with um effectively the Democrats
seemed to beat him on the budget the
Democrats beat him by denying the border
wall uh and that's not going to happen
with me um I'm going to get all these
things done if you look in Florida uh
not only did we not add to our state's
debt I paid down 25% of our state's debt
uh just since 2019 we cut taxes every
year we ban Sanctuary cities we even
help transport illegal aliens to
Sanctuary jurisdictions like Martha's
Vineyard which really helped change the
dynamic on that whole issue uh so on
issue after issue we've actually
delivered and I've delivered on 100% of
my promises you know Donald Trump was
not able to do that uh but I also don't
like the way he gets involved in some of
the the pettiness that he does that's
just not how I roll uh you know we all
we look higher uh we set a good example
uh but we're tough when it comes to
contrasting on issues judgment and
results I have the results I right on
the issues um and I'd be the better
choice for president all right yay yay
he's going against Donald
Trump
yay Ronda santz is Oh
yay
yay he's against Donald Trump so we
should be for him right that's what we
should do we should be for him just like
Chris Christie's against Donald Trump
Liz Cheney is against Donald Trump right
we should be for Ronda santis right
is that what we should
do I don't know I thought I thought
that's what you
wanted didn't you want didn't you want
to
be for people who were against Donald
Trump who were anti-donald Trump that's
what you wanted right give you a two
word answer Donald
Trump it's what you wanted it's what you
wanted let's listen to what he has to
say though about separation of church
and state let's let's hear about the the
part about the Theocratic fascism though
how does faith guide you and give people
an example of where you relied on that
and made a decision as Governor because
of that but then the other side of that
from these folks is how do you make sure
that there exists a separation between
church and state essentially well uh
faith in God is just uh you know who I
am and and and my faith is my Foundation
it's it's how I am able to uh deal with
issues uh when the seas are choppy when
people are gunning for you you know I
put on that full armor of God and that
allows me to have the strength to be
able to lead uh we saw this when my my
wife uh got diagnosed with breast cancer
uh okay here's how they do it here's how
they do they play to your emotions
remember he's anti-trump so you're like
Yay Ron santz is now anti-trump yay and
then he placed your emotions with the
cancer thing now watch major thing I
mean our kids were four a three and one
at the time and we didn't know you know
what was going to happen we the prayers
we got from people not just in Florida
but throughout the country uh lifted her
spirits it lifted our family Spirits in
a way that was really powerful and I'm
firsthand believer in the power of
prayer and as Governor I think I would
not have been able to stand strong um
during covid during some of the fights
we had where we beat Disney on the the
transgender ideology keeping that out of
the schools and the elementary schools
uh because you got a lot of people that
gun for you uh and so I think having
that that that Faith uh the faith in God
really gives you the foundation uh where
you're standing strong for what's right
now in terms of how that relates beyond
that I mean we're a diverse country I
mean I've gone to just in Iowa I've gone
to a number of different denominations
and they all have you know great
traditions and and that's government
needs to be neutral amongst that I mean
you oh government needs to be neutral
amongst the Christian
denominations I don't know if you're
picking up or smelling what he's stepp
Happ in but it is [__] white
Christian
nationalism when you sit and you say oh
there's a great diversity of religions
in our in our country and there should
be there should be plenty of
denominations there should be Baptist
and Luthers and and and Baptist
Methodist maybe those who would give up
their lives for Jesus um maybe maybe may
maybe non denominal I mean there could
be that too those that array of
denominations oh my God the diversity of
Christian denominations out there that's
the diversity that we are going to have
because he just got done telling you
that he won with Disney which he didn't
win with Disney he just passed laws to
try to [__] take away parents' rights
from
trans that have trans children he
literally Stripped Away rights from
people in Florida that had trans and and
the lgbtq children and he's trying to
ostracize and and eradicate people from
his state that are
lgbtq believe him when he says it all
right and he's saying the same [__] that
the weirdo that weirdo I just showed you
who you're like who is this Tony who
gives a [__] what this guy says about
the separation between church and state
what does it matter what does it matter
what does it matter get on with the
Trump motions in court Tony tell us what
the Trump motions are in court so I can
have my wankas them
tell us about the true social post that
Trump posted listen folks this
[__] election isn't about
Trump it's about us [__] beating the
fascist and he's the cult leader of them
yes so yeah he's kind of like the
[__] main target most of the
time but we have to beat them with
[__] narrative narrative narrative
narrative not some [__] video about
some [__] post he made or some
[__] motion that he filed in court
pluck your head out of your ass and pay
attention to the problem and let's fix
that [__]
problem and let me tell you something
the message that he wants to be a
[__] dictator and he's going to take
away your [__] rights and they're
going to do it through white Christian
nationalism is no better messaging it
won't it will win this is just
fundamentally what he's saying in this
clip is
unamerican I don't give a [__] who
you're talking to you can stand around
all day long and try to convince some
[__] that $3 gas is because of
Biden and you will argue and argue and
argue and argue and argue and they will
never [__] admit
it but you show
them what the [__] Republican party
has become
and I guarantee they like whoa whoa whoa
what they W to do what you know there's
not going to be an established
denomination versus others but we are a
country that is based on the idea that
our rights come from God not from the
government that's in the Declaration of
Independence and you absolutely have a
right uh to not just go to church on
Sunday and practice your faith there but
to live your faith uh in what you do uh
in your daily Liv we're going to make
sure that we restore religious liberty
in this country because when you have
situations where a football coach like
coach Kennedy is losing his job in
Washington state because he led a
voluntary prayer at Midfield after a
high school game uh he has to go all the
way to the Supreme Court that is not
what our founding fathers intended they
in they absolutely intended uh that your
faith would be an important part of who
you are and that you have a right as a
free citizen uh to live that out to the
fullest no matter what your denomination
as long as it's Christian and as long as
you follow our
rules listen to me when I'm telling you
this stop watching [__] videos about
the [__] Trump motions who gives a
rat's
ass that trial is going to be delayed
gonna be delayed hopefully that the
[__] DC trial is scheduled sometime
in August September that's what I'm
hoping for I'm hoping judge Chuck punts
it to about August
25th September 2nd something like that
right that's when I want that trial to
happen that's when I want that trial to
happen because he's GNA be saying all
kinds of dictator type [__] dictator
this dictator that Hitler this Hitler
that Grandpa Hitler won't be able to
stop talking about mine in August
September when he's going on trial for
trying to overthrow our government like
Hitler did
his
get with it know
it know what is at stake know the
message that we have to drive from now
until then from now until then we don't
have that much time by the way we are in
2024 it's January
3D we only got a limited amount of time
to drive this message and make sure
that it gets embedded inside the
Americans brains because again if you
stand around trying to argue that
biomics is good for gas prices you're
you're [__] you're just wasting your
breath show them this and and that's
government needs to be neutral amongst
that I mean you know there's not going
to be an established denomination versus
oh there's not going to be established
denomination established religion though
they want a
theocracy they want a
theocracy it's fundamentally
unamerican they know it we know
it so get with it start the messaging
start the narrative work your way in any
situation in any
situation in any conversation to
that yes they're going to use white
Christian nationalism to make Trump the
dictator to take away rights like they
did Ro
Wade
period period and Republicans really
understand this [__] like they get this
simple messaging um you remember I'm GNA
show you a clip here of comr pile and
not
because I want to show you comr pile not
because I I want to make a point here
about messaging
narrative and how I know what the [__]
I'm talking about um you remember uh
back before Thanksgiving remember they
were trying to keep the government open
closed and I said they're probably gonna
once they got Johnson on board which
surprised me I actually didn't think
they were gonna elect John I was totally
wrong about that I'm excited that he's
that that um um mikro Johnson is the the
wiener of the house I'm excited about
that I know most people aren't but I'm
excited about that because he's only
going to show his true colors that's
great he's a white Christian nationalist
he's down to like two any down to two
votes there's another Republican who
dropped down I mean [__] by this time by
the time we get rid of of criminal
Republicans because of federal
indictments in the house by the summer
I'm sure Hakeem Jeff will be the [__]
speaker of the house anyways right he he
might he might be I mean I'm not I'm not
going to predict that right now but I'm
saying there is a chance this year that
hem Jeff becomes the speaker before the
election and proves the American people
who the who the [__] actually gets [__]
done with their with their [__] votes
because the votes that they make on the
house floor are our [__]
votes but you remember when Mike Johnson
I was wrong about it Mike Johnson became
the speaker of the house right right he
became the speaker of the house and then
and then he decided to keep the
government open even though the last
speaker got kicked out because he kept
the government open he kept the
government open and I said it was
because Mike Johnson convinced Donald
Trump this is the truth this is what
actually probably [__] happened I
mean I know I'm you know postulating
here but can't you hear this
conversation look Mike I just want to
shut the government down they're after
me they're gonna put me in jail I
committed High crimes and misdemeanors
it's a real thing I tried to steal
documents I tried to overthrow the
government I mean you were there you
tried to help you know you know this you
know this and Mike Johnson's like yeah
but we really gota we really got to kick
this
past I just you gotta Kick this past the
holidays so no one's talking about how
we shut down the government because we
don't want to be blame for it let's do
it in January let's just do it in Jan
and I said that's what they were gonna
do they were gonna punt it to January
and then we're gonna have this big
[__] is the government going to be
open fight in January here we are by the
way
that was
correct but listen this is how narrative
works this is how National messaging
works the Republicans understand this
even a dumb Dum like comr pile
understands this why most of the left
doesn't get this I have no idea I'm
going to keep pounding it in your brains
until they do get it um but I said
remember when I said Republicans kept
the government open so that people
wouldn't talk about it how it was closed
during the holidays this is how their
brain works well here's here's comr pile
of course he's lying he's full of [__]
here but listen to what he says around
the world that's a basic question every
American Family asked around the dinner
table both during Thanksgiving and
Christmas break what exactly did the
bidens do to receive this money and why
won't Joe Biden be honest about his
involvement and knowledge in his family
Shady business scheme so and no one
thought that that no one said that
that's not a thing that happened people
did not sit around the Christmas and
Thanksgiving dinner table and talk about
Joe Biden Hunter dick I mean there's a
lot of Maga like cultist like you know
10 12% of the country that really
probably tried to talk about that [__]
but they probably had a f was like look
shut the [__] up or get the [__] out
okay we're here to have Christmas I'm
not here to talk about Hunter Biden's
[__] okay I know you're obsessed with
[__] and Hunter Biden's dick we're not
talking about it today give it to me
give it to me give it to
me but they weren't talking about Joe
Biden they weren't but here's the thing
Comer's giving away the game when he
says that because that was their plan
all along their sell to Trump listen to
me listen they're sell to Trump when
they went to him to tell him hey we need
to keep the government open so they'll
talk about Biden over the
holidays not the government shutting
down
I said it it happened here's the
evidence that I was right because comr
pile is saying it out loud it's how
their brains work
honestly if we had enough sense in us on
the left it would be how our [__]
brain
works it's
not it's
not it's not how our brain works Oops I
did the wrong one hang on
it's not how our brain
works our brains do not work that way
the American people the left now the
American people's brains work that way
not the
left whoosh all right let's get to H
let's make fun of Nikki Haley and rad
damad dingdong then we'll go to Green
Day really quick here's rad damama
dingdong talk to some old fat
guy and here it is she'll be set a good
example for children in this talking
about his wife
simple message that's your wife that's
right she you you've seen her yeah
simple Elegance thank you thank she
doesn't have a she doesn't make a big
production out of it she doesn't have an
a six ax handles white
either your wife doesn't have an ass
that's 6X handles wide either coming
from the fat [__] slob and
overalls oh that's a great clip I love
that clip I'm sorry I gota I got to show
that clip um let's go to the Nikki Haley
clip real quick and then we'll go to the
and then we'll go to the Green Day the
Green Day [__] because I got to get to
that I got to show the Green Day stuff
you know it's been
um here we go here's here's Nikki Haley
I I'll play a little bit of this uh
she's attacking Donald Trump now in New
Hampshire now we weeks out and I see
commercials that you see yeah and I've
noticed that President Trump has given
me
oh and I
app but in his commercials and in his
temper
Changs every single thing that he said
has been a alive every single one I
looked for some great of Truth every
single
one Park
grind Park
grind
we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds this
is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy pel's mail
do you feel exposed to a government that
doesn't share your patriotic values if
any of these describe you then you're in
luck hi I'm Paul goar and thanks to my
new product paron blanket I've got you
covered paron blanket specifically Works
to make you feel safe and cozy after
your involvement on January 6th and if
you're one of the other members of
Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too Hardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're 100% made in
the USA don't delay and get your pardon
blanket today for just
$99.99 actual pardon not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels
podcast
oh man oh man oh man oh man
rules had a little bit of technical
difficulty there [__] just shut off yeah
I'm
here I'm here I'm
here can you hear
me testing one two one two testing
testing testing testing
testing it happens it happens you know
[__] um here's the Green Day clip we're
GNA skip over the the um the Nikki Haley
stuff might have to cut a few of them
out next
question um here's the Green Day clip
that everyone's pissed off about now I'm
probably gonna get knocked for this but
I want to show it anyways to you um
because the fash doesn't understand what
punk rock is they have no clue
that that punk rock wouldn't be for
Donald Trump just because he's not
president like that's what they believe
like oh well Joe Biden is the president
so he's the
establishment
um yeah that's that's what yeah
and kind of sort of
thing but Trump's trying to be the
establishment I'm against this St it's
weird it's you know like ideas and stuff
but here's Green Day changing the lyrics
see if you can spot it an American
[Music]
Idiot part of the Maga agenda okay now
the original
lyric um in case you didn't know
is the original lyric is Redneck agenda
that's the the thing so like maanga is
like a sect of redneck ISM right like
redneck ism is so much bigger and green
day is kind of anti- redneck they are
like where I grew up most people didn't
really like um rednecks or I mean didn't
like green day because they were
rednecks and they were talking about the
redneck agenda but they changed it to
MAA agenda and ma was really upset they
were like oh this I'm punk rock but [__]
Green Day because Green Day should be
anti-establishment like you are an
established cult you [__] boneheads
how don't you know this oh and by the
way if you think that Billy with green
day is gonna be for Trump because Trump
isn't President maybe I'll give you a
little taste of
this
Amer One Nation controll by the media
information and
[Music]
TR
[Applause]
did you catch it did you catch it here
watch
watch what made maanga think that green
day was gonna be for
manga
they're so [__] dumb how how are they
so [__] two answer Donald Trump how
are they so [__] dumb how how is this
possible that they didn't
know that Green Day in their show during
the [__] song American Idiot has been
saying [__] Donald Trump and that
somehow they because they weren't going
to say it on the New Year's Eve thing
[__] Donald Trump because they were
contracted on television so they can't
yell [__] Donald Trump right so they
changed the lyric from redneck agenda to
Maga agenda to make the same [__]
point MAA loses their
minds I can't believe he's anti-donald
Trump Donald Trump is anti-establishment
do you know what an establishment is you
bonehead what do you think what do you
think the Republican party is what do
you think him controlling the Republican
party what do you think him controlling
the [__] manga cult is it's
establishment you [__] bonehead do
you not know what [__] punk rock is
it's against all establishments
especially one trying to oppress the
rights of people which maa's design the
design of Maga is to oppress the rights
of people and that's the
message they want to oppress your rights
and your neighbors rights by making
Donald Trump the dictator and King and
using Christ white Christian nationalism
to make him Grandpa Hitler and they're
gonna take your [__] rights away just
like they took women's rights away by
stripping them of row v
Wade that's your message every [__]
time over and over and over and over and
over again stop listening to the noise
and make the correct sound
[__] Donald Trump [__] [__] Grandpa
Hitler [__] fascist [__] these nut Nazis
and [__] white Christian nationalism
[__] them [__] them [__] them [__] them
tomorrow same time same place you sons
of [__] surf sub
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast podast in your
face commentary of current events in
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at thee Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them
Murphy's mebor head ass
speaking
we take our next steps into the world
you must go forth into the world it is
with passion passion courage of
conviction courage in your convictions
and most importantly most importantly
have faith in yourself be true to
yourself we did it I did it
yeah